what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with fall of X not to be
confused with the video that we recently
did where all the superheroes died that
was Days of Future Past totally
different story so what this does here
is this basically picks up with Kitty
Pride who as we've discussed in recent
weeks is absolutely dope right assassin
Kitty Pride you guys love her man you
guys love seeing Kitty pride is like an
assassin that can phase through objects
and what she ends up doing is making her
way into an orcus prison facility where
Cyclops is being held now for those of
you guys who are not current with fall
of X as always we'll have a playlist
that you can click on at the end of this
video so you can get caught up but one
of the things we saw at the very
beginning of fall of X when orcus made
their move and attacked all the X-Men we
saw Juggernaut facing off against Nimrod
this kind of ultimate Sentinel and
Nimrod seemingly killed Juggernaut turns
out he's not dead the juggernaut's very
much alive which makes perfect sense
because at the time it was kind of like
okay I guess this is just like a
grandiose Display of nimrod's Power but
it seems kind of weird that Juggernaut
would be killed by Nimrod that just
seems a little strange to me the dude's
alive which is awesome but Kitty Pride
as we know kind of following her story
over the miscellaneous X-Men books she's
kind of going through and basically
getting a headcount for those mutants
specifically members of the X-Men who
have been captured by orcus and who are
still alive when she goes into the next
room she find Cyclops there now we knew
Cyclops was being held captive we knew
they had sewn his eyes shut so we
couldn't use his optic blast and he's
just kind of been held there under
normal circumstances she would just free
him but what we end up learning is that
he's actually on a dead man's trigger
that in effect if she tries to remove
him from where he's being held a bomb
will detonate somewhere now she doesn't
know where that bomb is and most likely
it's in the proximity of that space and
most likely it's in that room so it
would kill Cyclops and whoever it is
that tried to free him which is really
just kind of a testament to how far
forward orcus was thinking in regards to
like the X-Men retaliating and trying to
free one of their own especially Cyclops
right he's like a core member of the
team and has been a core member of the
team since its original Inception the
other part of this is that she ends up
freeing Juggernaut but she tells him do
not Escape yet right do not leave now
like I still have to go get a headcount
if you do it could complicate matters
right so I'm asking you to do the one
thing that you won't want to do the most
which is just stay here now as for how
juggernaut's alive he basically says
it's the Crimson gem inside his chest
right that he's still seemingly the
Juggernaut that we all know and love in
terms of power but the Crimson gem also
speeds up his healing for those of you
guys who don't know about Juggernaut the
Crimson Gem of citak the source of his
power advanced healing Incredible
strength once he starts moving he cannot
be stopped unless the writer who's
writing that comic wants him to be
stopped uh and that's basically it right
the guy can breathe in space he doesn't
need food water all that kind of stuff
the guy is literally a living Juggernaut
and so following that what you do is you
pick up in the Morlock tunnels with
Rasputin who again is a Time displace
mutant from the future that is actually
five mutants in one so she's got the
phasing ability of kitty Pride the
telepathy of Quinton choir meaning she's
one of the most powerful telepaths in
existence the organic skin of Colossus
and the claw of x23 you've also got sink
who can basically duplicate the powers
of anybody who's around him and then
you've got kamalak Khan who seemingly
done nothing entire time so and what
they're doing here is they're basically
sitting around pondering their next
mission which is to say going and
finding Reed Richards of the Fantastic 4
in order to gain information that had
been or at least was believed to have
been removed from his mind by Professor
Xavier but their belief is really less
that the information had been removed
and more that the information had just
been hidden from Reed so he couldn't
actually access it but regardless they
end up basically grabbing a car and
traveling to where the Fantastic Four
are residing outside of New York just
kind of taking a reprieve of course
Rasputin being from the future and being
incredibly socially awkward instead of
just like seeing Ben grim and just being
like hey what's going on uh we need your
help she just like calls him a Gollum
and then punches him and like sends him
flying which is
amazing because the whole time she's
doing this like the other X-Men are like
oh my God like the Fantastic for are
friends right but because she's just so
weird and socially awkward she doesn't
quite get that you know and so she's
like matters are escalating they need
not I've simply come here for
information the funny thing is she's met
by Johnny Storm and then using the power
of Quinton choir right his telepathy she
shuts his mind down and then that's when
she's met by the arrival of Reed and
Susan storm now let me tell you guys
something if you guys are not familiar
with the Fantastic 4 if like you never
read Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic 4 you
don't understand how powerful Susan
storm is people sleep on how powerful
Susan storm is is right like this girl
held off the power of celestials like
celestials were trying to destroy her
and Reed Richards in them and she
literally popped a shield right that
kept her protected that happened in I
want to say it was fantastic 4 issue
number 603 it was crazy when that
happened right it was absolutely amazing
but what goes on here is that when she
approaches Mr Fantastic right like he
literally tells her I am the guy you're
looking for and I hope for your sake
that my family is unharmed because sure
she might be able to like attack him in
the moment and knock him out but let me
tell you something man when Reed Richard
sets his mind on destroying you there's
no hope for you there's nowhere you can
go to be safe from Reed Richard's
intellect that as smart as that guy is
yeah man that guy will kill you then
he'll go to work on you you know what I
mean like it's just one of those things
right that dude's just hardcore but what
she does is she says like we need to
access your mind and she uses her
telepathy to kind of forcefully enter
the mind of Reed now one of the things
to know is that within the superhero
Community there's just a Litany of
Unwritten rules right you know drink
Pepsi don't drink Coca-Cola but one of
the rules here is also that you don't
like forcefully enter the mind of an
ally it's something that you just don't
do right it's just bad form to do that
and so in that moment like Susan storm
pops a force field around Rasputin to
kind of shut down her ability to access
Reed's mind and he even tells her like
that's not going to happen again now
that happened because Reed simply wasn't
prepared for it he did kind of
understand what her powers were but
everything happened so fast that he
wasn't able to respond in time but Reed
is perfectly capable of instilling
mental blocks or maintaining mental
blocks in his own head that would
prevent somebody with really any level
of telepathy from entering into his mind
forcefully and a lot of that just comes
by way of his experience with the X-Men
the fact that the Fantastic 4 fought the
X-Men and Marvel his dealings with
galatis and seemingly any and other
Cosmic entities in between but of course
Rasputin having the phasing ability of
kitty Pride just walks right through the
force field but once everything calms
down and Ben Grim gets punched again you
actually end up having Miss Marvel who
meets Reed Richards which is cool right
it's kind of cool to like see them
encounter one another and kind of like
talk for a moment and sort of like high
five because their powers are very
similar and read Because Marvel's kind
of forcing it on all of us is just like
oh yeah you know like you got your
powers from the ter and miss which under
normal circumstances would kill a mutant
but because the plot demanded it you
survived because the Marvel Cinematic
Universe made you a mutant and now
Marvel Comics has to do it even though
no one asked for it or wants it so the
thing about this is once they enter into
the mind of Reed you get this really
interesting moment where they realized
that what Professor Xavier had done is
he had hollowed the knowledge out of
Reed Richard's mind now there is a lot
of kind of discussion here right Reed
says like as I suspected the brain it
can mend and it can change it's valuable
I will work around this I'll find a way
to gain the information that you need
but we don't definitively really even
know if that's possible right because
Professor Xavier is such a incredible
telepath it's very difficult to actually
pull that off it's almost impossible to
do right like once he removes Knowledge
from your brain there's seemingly no way
for you to really get it back they would
actually have to go find Professor
Xavier and get the information but they
don't know the status of Professor
Xavier they don't know that he's sitting
on the mutant nation of kcoa right the
island of kcoa and is out there doing
his own thing right and kind of fighting
off anybody who tries to invade the
island they think he's dead right and so
what ends up happening is that once the
X-Men basically leave right and Reed
just kind of continues to work on his
own mind trying to find this information
if it even can be found that there is a
bit of musing By the Fantastic Four who
really kind of talk about how orcus is a
problem for everybody because orcus
going after the mutant population it's
not going to end there right like
superheroes in general will rally
against orcus in favor of the mutant
population yes they want to maintain
public support and public opinion is so
against the mutant population if the
Avengers seemingly came out publicly in
favor of the X-Men Humanity might turn
against them with the Fantastic 4 it
could very well be the same thing is it
kind of crummy to sort of just sit on
the sidelines and kind of wait and see
how things transpire and then decide who
the winning is going to be and then
intervene accordingly absolutely it's a
really crappy thing to do but hey you
know being a superhero is nothing if not
a game of politics and so at that point
you switch over to this really really
cool moment at the ending of this where
you've got Sinister talking to Firestar
now remember Firestar was there during
the Hellfire Gala she is a member of the
X-Men but before Jean Gray died she had
tricked the mind of sinister into
believing that Firestar was the one that
fed them information that allowed them
to launch their attack in the first
place which allows firear to be on the
inside of orcus and gain information and
what Sinister reveals is that quote
unquote somehow or another Juggernaut
had escaped the adamantium collar that
was around his neck Nimrod responded
pummeled his head in a few times and put
the collar back around his neck again
but what Sinister also realized is that
with Juggernaut having the Crimson Gem
of citak inside of his chest it makes
him too powerful and too dangerous to
try to pacify so what Sinister intends
to do is find some way to basically make
Juggernaut unconscious remove the
Crimson gem from his chest and instill
it in himself now whether or not that'll
work we don't fully know because it's
one thing to be in possession of the
Crimson gym it's another to have the
blessing of citak and if you do not have
the blessing of that entity that just
astronomically stupid powerful entity in
the Crimson Dimension then you're
basically just holding a use chunk of
rock but we'll find out what happens in
the next X-Men video with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you need to get caught up on
fall of X make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace